[موسيقى]
انت بتعرف يا صديقي العزيز ان الخارطه
السياسيه والخريطه المجتمعيه للمنطقه
اصابها تغيرات كانت تصادمين انا لم اصل
مرحله الياس هناك فرق بين كيف تقرا الواقع
كيف تقرا
ولا بد من التميز بين الياس والاحباط
الياس من اعلى واوضح اوانينه وعدم الانجاز
لا انا خلال سنوات الحرب استطيع ان اقول
لك ان كان ان انجازي كان كثيفا جدا سواء
في السينما او في الادب او في المسرعه
وكنت اقلهم في التلفزيون لم انجز سوى ثلاث
مسلسلات عبر عشر سنوات لكن احنا بالحاله
الثقافيه العامه للاسف هلا اصبحت الدراما
التلفزيونيه هي مرجعيه حضورك يعني عندما
تغيب عن الدراما الت
يفتقدك الناس يبدو لانها اكثر الوسائل
تاثيرا والشيوعا وانتشارا بس انا خلال هذه
السنوات انجلت حوالي ثمان افلام روائيه
خمسه منها كممثل وثلاث مناك مخرج ايه
وانجزت حوالي ثمان مسرحيات ايضا
وخمس مجموعات همم ادبيه بين القصه وبين
السير الذاتيه
[موسيقى]
لا انا عبرت عما اصابني من هذه الحرب كل
هذه الالام انا رميتها على اوراق احيانا
او على شريط سينمائي حاولت ان اقول ما
احسس به حاولت ان يؤثر ما مررنا به لانه
بعتبر واحد من اردوان الرئيسيه ان نكون
موثقين بلحظه من لحظات لهذه الذاكره كي
عندما تاتي الاجيال تعرف عبر عمل فني وليس
عبر القراءات سياسيه اصطفافيه عبر عمل فني
على مسافه واحده من الاشياء يمكن لها ان
تقرا همم احساس الناس في تلك يعني في
المجال الذي نهتم به عملته بهذا الحيه
الطويله وبالتالي هذا سبب لي غياب عن
الدراما التلفزيونيه سنوات طويله كان في
شعور بقليل من ما بيسمي الياس من الاحباط
لكن لم يصل الحدود عدم الانجاز
[موسيقى]